dans sébastien vialatte pour le groupe
l'est républicain merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
elle concerne la réforme de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement des communes
et la suppression de la dotation de
provocation voté hier soir
monsieur le premier ministre loin de moi
l'idée de vouloir polémiquer avec le
gouvernement loin de moi l'idée que
cette réforme a été mal préparé non
concertée sans étude d'impact et sans
mesure des conséquences sur certaines
communes
je souhaite simplement attirer
l'attention du gouvernement sur quelques
dizaines de communes qui subiront la
triple peine en 2017
nous avons appris dans un gros quotidien
du soir que nous commune subirait la
baisse de la dgf la contribution au
redressement des finances publiques et
la perte de la dotation nationale de
péréquation
cela représente une perte brutale de 30%
voire plus de leurs dotations les
conséquences seraient dramatiques remise
en cause du service public de proximité
augmentation importante de la fiscalité
arrêt des investissements avec des
conséquences immédiates sur le chômage
c'est comme une telle commis une faute
pour risquer d'être aussi lourdement
pénalisés sont elles aujourd'hui ce bien
doté si je prends une commune comme la
mienne
la dotation est de 195 euros par
habitant alors que la moyenne de la
strate est de 257 euros
et pourtant six fours subir à la triple
peine
je sais monsieur le premier ministre que
vous avez déclaré au sénat que dans la
future réforme peu de communes serait
père tente et que de nombreux serait au
contraire favoriser cette réforme est
injuste
le vote de cette nuit reporte d'un an
l'application pour autant la baisse des
dotations départs échelonnés comme les
élus locaux vous le demande
la rave le report de la réforme ne fait
que maintenir les maires dans
l'incertitude dans un climat
d'instabilité ils n'ont aucune
visibilité sur leurs budgets
pourquoi pourquoi ne pas supprimer
définitivement la réforme et crée de
facto un climat de travail constructif
et serein avec les élus locaux
merci monsieur vialatte la parole est à
mme la ministre d'aller centralisation
et la fonction publique
merci monsieur le président mesdames
le député monsieur débuté les valeurs
vous avez participé au débat c'est vrai
que la réforme de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement a été commencé bien avant
mars avril et on a eu un seul souci
c'est de réparer des injustices et
malheureusement je le dis parce que le
ton de votre question est un ton très
apaisé jeudi avec autant d'apaisement
nous avons eu du mal à travailler avec
le cfl sur nos simulations et donc nous
avons été un peu ralentie par un refus
de l'ensemble des associations d'élus de
travailler le sujet mais c'est important
de rappeler quand même qu'aujourd'hui la
dotation c'est à dire la dotation de
l'état à nos collectivités locales est
extrêmement injuste puisqu'elle fait
passer la moyenne des ressources des
collectivités avant la dotation de 292
euros par habitant à après les dotations
305 euros par habitant il ya un vrai
souci de justice il ya un souci aussi de
lisibilité
il ya vingt-et-une 21/01/10 qui compte
pour calculer la dgf
aucun maire ne peut savoir projeté
calculer sa propre dgf
et enfin il ya aussi une forte demande à
la fois des communes urbaines et des
communes rurales de prendre en compte
deux choses la ruralité c'est à dire les
superficies la montagne les forêts les
zones de protection des captages et c
est pour les urbains de prendre en
compte des charges de centralité que la
commune soit petit ou grand nous avons
proposé trois indices une dotation
unique pour tous les habitants une
dotation de centralité une dotation dure
réalité
la dgf ne peut pas être plus simple mais
le premier ministre devant l'opposition
de l'ensemble ou ne presque l'ensemble
des associations d'élus du président du
sénat et de votre groupe et de quelques
parlementaires de notre groupe a décidé
de prendre le temps donc vous
participerez avec nous un groupe de
travail intéressant sous l'autorité de
ce quart aise
merci madame ministre la parole à madame